[Music]
welcome back to GameSpot's best for 2017
countdown we just announced the super
mario odyssey was our number three game
of 2017 as its cited on by GameSpot
staff I won't keep you waiting to get
into this montage of a game that I'm
sure will surprise everyone let's do it
[Music]
trickster
[Music]
welcome to my Velvet Room
[Music]
it's not
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I am thou thou art I thou hast acquired
a new vow it shall become the wings of
rebellion that break it by chains of
captivity
[Music]
[Applause]
persona 5 from Atlas is our number 2
game of 2017 so I brought on a bunch of
persona 5 fans Michael hi I'm yo John
Luke sucky jumped off the track asked
her to come talk about yeah
and as always Peter Brown I'm still here
and yeah a lot of people argue pretty
vehemently for this game Michael you
were one of them why this is similarly
on our number two spot Oh a lot of
reasons I'll tell you that
start with one okay I'll start with the
themes it tackles okay so the persona 5
is very much about authority figures
about people in power who abuse their
power and influence in very devious ways
and you know as these Japanese high
school students you put your foot down
and you say no you're not getting away
with that [ __ ] and that's that's very
powerful within itself but it the
premise gets deeper and deeper and what
you soon realize as you it sprinkled out
through throughout the game but it kind
of builds up to this notion that you
know society's problems go much deeper
than individual people like they can be
like like very shitty people they can do
terrible things but like it goes deeper
than that like only one person has so
much power and then what you soon kind
of realize is that you know as a society
as a collective group of people you know
you have to you know do something about
it if you want to make changes and
that's kind of a central theme to the
game as you know fighting for change and
then you know I was playing yesterday
and there's this moment where Morgana
asks the main character the cat you're
psychic yeah psychic the teddy figure I
suppose in persona 5 ain't better than
Teddy yeah yeah I definitely ground that
but he asks you something and he looks
at you and says why don't people do
anything about the bad things that
happen in this world and you have three
answers and it's like they can't they
don't have the power to or they don't
care or they like it's not beneficial to
them to act out or they're lazy that's
that's pretty much the most universal
human trait yeah and that's a stir ya
know
I said but like John Luke over the
course of the game as you're actually
going into the so like the premise is
like as phantom thieves you have the
power to essentially go into people's
minds their subconscious their kind of
their mental layout and you get to
change their hearts so to speak but
they're divided into separate dungeons
in each person it's almost like you're
diving into each person's psyche how do
those dungeons play out over the course
of the game or they how they creatively
laid out do they kind of morph over the
course of game what do you think of them
yeah I mean they kind take a different
approach the past percent of games have
been using sort of like a randomized
layout dungeon yeah procedural dungeons
and this game yeah they're much more
intentionally laid out and I almost kind
of akin them to sometimes they have like
a Dark Souls sort of like spiral kind of
loop design yeah where you have the save
points and then as you're going through
the game you will either get new save
points or sometimes you'll unlock
shortcuts that go back to like the same
end point there's this one dungeon that
has like a central kind of like long
chamber and then each one kind of keeps
looping back into that Center so they do
clever things like that to kind of keep
the dungeon layout interesting compared
to the previous games yes but a lot more
like puzzles yes and stuff and I this is
my first persona game ever but it was
one of my favorite games out of 2017 but
it did remind me of like a traditional
Zelda dungeon kind of like how each of
them are specific theme like we're gonna
play one in a little bit livestream like
a bank vault it's laid out like a bank
vault and like the dungeon itself starts
rearranging and like more modern Zelda's
leaving breath of a while decide the
dungeons do kind of loop back in on
themselves so if it's like a puzzle box
dungeon if you watch like Marc Brown
stuff about them on YouTube but what
about the combat here Michael as far as
figuring out certain enemies weaknesses
like you know like personae are actual
are like the things you can control each
person has their own and the Joker the
main character he can control a bunch of
them you capture them or and then you
can actually use them against the ones
you encounter in these dungeons or in
mementos the be kind of just like for
that's procedural and so far as that's
what you're doing between dungeons but
how does that combat affect your notion
of the game as you're going through it
so this was also my first game in the
line of Shin Megami Tensei games but
it's
it's essentially at the foundation it's
a very similar combat system as you've
seen in previous SMT games and persona
games but it's it's very much refined in
this way that you know it's when you're
in battle especially tough battles it's
almost trying to figure out a puzzle
like okay this character like in any
really good turn-based RPG you kind of
have to figure out okay whose turn is it
next do I need to heal a certain person
who might be attacked or buff their
stats and or can I hit this particular
enemy enemies weakness so I can get
another turn or give it to someone else
like tag that yeah and you can do a
baton pass and pass it someone else if
you have your social linked high enough
or confidant
yes feeling when you oh yeah well I want
to talk about compounds the best feeling
when you you have like four different
enemies and you use like a shock we can
someone pass it off to someone with a
fire attack and then you actually just
pass baton like four times you can just
keep going infinitely until they're dead
yes of the knowing the enemy's weakness
is kind of the key key part of this
particular turn-based system because you
get that extra turn and you can knock
them down and you know it's and
sometimes you just can't you can't even
figure out their weakness as well
especially lost battles so then you kind
of have to think okay well if I don't
have that in my back pocket you know who
do I need to buff what items can I use
to make sure that you know my characters
don't die or I can boost them so they
can be even more damage before that
enemy has their turn so it's this
constant puzzle that you have to figure
out and then throughout between the
dungeons you're preparing for each
dungeon almost like you might a heist
you're kind of planning out we're gonna
go in like this like you're just you're
building your team and then you're also
developing confidant so I want to ask
Michael about that but the everyday life
in this Tokyo setting John Luke when
you're going between like batting cages
or going to eat burgers or and
everything you're doing is increasing
your social stats how does that part of
the game complement the dungeons in a
combat like this you know I would assume
before I played the game that this would
be the boring part but that's not the
case in this game no I mean I think
there's a lot of people who like prefer
this part like put the game on easy
because this is the part of the game
they like to experience I think they
integrated a lot better in this one so
in previous persona games you would
talk to your social links or confidants
and you would basically as you rank up
with them it allows you to create more
powerful personas which you can give us
you boost in combat but in this one they
have more tangible benefits as well
where okay I want to hang out with this
politician who is on the screen right
now and then doing so actually increases
my chances of talking to the shadows and
getting being able to like get more
personas eventually you can do more
benefits like that like there's
characters there's amazing social link
that I wish I'd done more of because
this person gives you the ability to
swap party members mid-battle yeah which
open it sounds like not chess but she's
the more game should be played fresh in
all should be playing yeah but like
opening that up gave me like a whole new
like suite of options yeah in the combat
like all of a sudden like okay now I can
I can try and like manage my SP better
by being like well I can swap this
character with this character this one's
weak and that becomes like really
critical and boss battle so I think they
do a lot better job just like providing
more for incentive to do this social
links and then just like that in turn
like makes the combat like way more
dynamic yeah and you mentioned you
touched on negotiations actually I want
to talk about those because that's you
don't always have to fight people in
fact a lot of times there are enemies
you're better off negotiating with
talking with you actually I mean you do
start I think you'e mentioned like you
do start to see through the cracks of
how they work like specific characters
you see the connection between what they
say yeah yeah I will say that still was
a good change of pace from the fighting
like figuring out oh they just said this
so that means they're kind of insecure
so then your next answer the follow-up
almost you have to play on that in order
to either become friends with them and
make them trust you or make them
intimidate them it's almost like a
psychoanalysis that makes the the combat
like a not secondary but it is a good
change of pace from the combat yeah it
keeps it interesting yeah what about the
negotiations did you were you doing
those often throughout the game like oh
I really like doing all-out attacks so
negotiations were kind of my secondary
option but you know you can juice them
for like even more money as well like as
you get better speech skills from anime
Bernie Sanders yeah and there you can
you can actually extort more money out
of the
so if like man I'm low on yen but I want
to buy a new equipment for my from my
party it's like you know I'm just gonna
keep asking them for more and more money
I didn't really use the ones with the
one where you can ask them for items
like I was just like ask for money to
buy the items I want and then like you
know wielding their power to create more
personas yeah it's almost like this
Pokemon desk kind of you know structure
in that when you capture their persona
know you can hinge their abilities or
you can fuse them in a very vicious
manner when you go to the Velvet Room
you literally like line them up on
guillotines chop their heads off making
them get like what is hanging them do
hanging them transfers skill power to a
different person to another persona it's
it's quite it's pretty dark yeah yeah
like The Velvet Room in general is
always creepy as hell with a Gore egora
dude voices he's missing character from
the game since the first game yeah but
like as you're building confidence John
Luke you're built some of them become
party members we don't have it on the
screen right now but in our room we see
like Makoto used to used to K these guys
used to K and then well this get in my
defense this game no the game says you
say you skate all time that's the one
they get right okay
whatever but in my defense this game did
not help me with my Japanese but yeah
tomorrow Hussein told me I would be dead
too if I didn't mention and agree with
him that Makoto is best girl she sure is
man yeah she's the student council
president and then like Britt starts
breaking out of that that's pronounced
motto starts breaking out of that she'll
I'll let you guys pronounce the names
for now and I'll just I'll give it all
that color commentary but like you're
developing these confidants some of them
just let you skills brothers become
party members and thematically and
narrative Lee it's interesting how
they're real I know this is nothing new
for the series but I really enjoyed how
the parts of them that they suppress
despite the fact that it really does
kind of dictate their personality come
out in the in these in the phantom world
whatever you want to call it versus yeah
meta first I was gonna say upside down
just for I think but did you uh did you
have any favorite characters or like
what was it like building the
relationship for these characters you
actually feel connected with them or did
you feel like it was just a gamified
kind of thing no you definitely feel
connected with them especially like
because the game lets you choose like
which ones do want to continue like
developing the earther so it's like okay
like I'm actually pretty invested in
macchiatos like relationship with her
sister and I can't want to explore that
further in the game helps you so the
game kind of like you get the stuff
through the main story and you you get
to kind of experience these characters
and but then also the game lets you like
choose which ones you kind of want to
like continue to explore and get to know
better and I mean you know this game's
long it's like a hundred hours but by
the end of it you like I think the
length works as far as like developing
that relationship with those characters
like it wouldn't mean nearly as much
watching if it was just like a 20-hour
thing or like a like a movie like
they're doing an anime of it and the
anime like they did one for four as well
and it was a good anime but you don't
get that same connection that you do
like putting a hundred hours into these
characters and deciding where to develop
the relationship like that yes so you
you as the player get to you feel like
this is your connection to the
characters and like you said when you I
play my first playthrough is 120 hours
and when you get to like sit on those
story beats and the development
developments of the relationships you
know you get to stop and think about
this you know things aren't always
happening you get to stop and smell the
roses for yeah lack of a better term and
I think that helps the character
development it helps you you know care
about your core cast and everyone else
that you kind of helps you along the way
and you know I I really felt connected
to this to this game and then it made me
want to go back and play the other
persona games and see what they had to
offer and you know those things are
there as well I feel feel very connected
to the cast of four and three and you
know five being able to portray that
even better and motivate someone to go
back in the series is quite powerful to
me and while we're watching the b-roll
just the sheer amazing [ __ ]
presentation in this game between the
soundtrack the transitions young live
you use a few of them in your montage
that you did that video earlier that we
watched and just everything about it
just exudes like style it's just the
most confident game ever and immediately
it hooks you it
right away I'm just super into the
universe I'm like when I first start
playing like whether I like this game or
not I respect what they're doing right
now and I ended up loving it was one of
my favorite games of 2017 but the more I
played it the more like they just like
even like the characters like when you
meet specific characters the way that
they're these screens and the loading
screens and the attack screens like the
all out attacks change for whoever
initiates the all-out attack based on
like like Ryu G's will be like a lot of
punk stuff speaking of for Yugi I do
want to get into it I did not like we're
usually at first but this kind of
encapsulate why I love this game
throughout I did a video essay earlier
in the year about why this reignited my
love for like Japanese style RPGs I
absolutely loved how it was constantly
subverting my expectations and messin
with RPG tropes in general like Ryu G
starts out as this angry punk kid it's
Brett yeah he's a brat and then you
start to figure out like you start to
hear his backstory and of course like
it's nothing new making you emphasize
the characters you might not think you
might but really became my favorite
character in a game outside of like
people you meet later on but it was just
the way it actually subverted like it
never felt like I was grinding even
though you kind of do have to at certain
points something when it comes to
mementos you might have to but I just
never felt like I was wasting a day
despite the fact that was time
management and this game was so good at
subverting JRPG narrative tropes and
gameplay tropes and like just RPG tropes
in general that it was constantly
keeping me guessing like I don't know
that any other game has do you find the
same thing Michael yeah definitely I
I've played a lot of JRPGs in my time as
well I grew up on them at a very young
age but here this is different because
you almost have this like social
simulator part to it which is kind of
what what drives you to care about this
world
in many ways and then so you know you
meet these characters first and then you
kind of have an initial impression but
of course you dig deeper and you learn
about their desires what drives them and
you know for example you said were you
GU kind of like once you get to the end
of his social link you kind of
understand like why he is the way he is
and like how he can be better even like
mocked Oh her initial intro in the game
is that she's like a a plus student
who's like a teacher's pet and stuff but
she's very conflicted even early on in
the game you know between her sister and
then akechi who's like
like being a like really smug to her and
then how the Phantom fees initially was
like you know she's just trying to get
us caught up she's a snitch and then
she's like nobody accepts me I'm trying
my best
yeah like I'm trying my best but nobody
accepts me but I do have this desire to
instill justice and I think that by way
of the phantom thieves I'm going to join
them and express everything that I've
been feeling since she was a kid because
if you go into her backstory and her
father and all that it's like she
finally unleashes that inner passion
yeah and she joins her party and that's
part of why you care about these
characters like their stories within
themselves aren't like revolutionary but
when you have like 10 15 of these
stories all put together driving to the
same goal I think that's what makes
persona fight cast and characters and
story very special and like a certain
point the game it starts to ask whether
what you're doing is actually just and
righteous I mean like a lot of
superheroes tales do that you're
essentially like psychic superheroes in
this game to be reductive but you
actually it starts a question whether
you're not the bad guys you are going
into people's minds and screwing with
their wiring to make them better people
so to speak and like a lot of them admit
their guilt and to become better people
but there are like implications that
come with that like is this even moral
to do that do you think the game did a
good job making you question your own
actions throughout John Luke oh
definitely at the end I mean they really
start to get into that I would say the
game maybe doesn't at the end it is sort
of like still like no we still did the
right thing and I and I I guess that
comes down to like how your personal
perspective because I felt like yeah I
think they did the right thing too
but the game definitely does make you
question that I'm like the characters
have like this you know crisis of faith
about what they're doing is right and
sort of yeah like the realization that
kind of like were you talking about that
it's just like society as a whole is the
problem and that like you know it's not
just about we can change we we have to
force this change on people it's we need
to get people to realize to make the
change themselves yes it's kind of like
the larger theme of the game and yeah
definitely not definitely not one note
like it does sprinkle that a little bit
of doubt but then by the end you like
kind of for your things that like know
how we doing the right thing
yeah and that's a really good feeling
too because when when the whole cast
that carries that you care about kind of
realized and then when you go into this
game that has so much style so much
confidence like even though main
characters like smirk and like every
time he does like the all-out attack and
stuff like that just like wow I really I
really believe in what they're doing and
what I'm doing along with them would you
name your main character I I did a shout
out to the Giant Bomb persona for
endurance really okay yeah charlie - no
no that's my boy I gotcha
I named him Acura because that's the
comic is a manga name for him so I got
just know that persona 5 one of the more
memorable games of this year
stylistically narrative Lee and the way
is it subverted its gianna it was one of
my favourite games of the year and a lot
of the GameSpot staff happen to agree so
that's why I got to our number two spot
if you're watching this on GameSpot or
YouTube after the fact please go catch
up on our first eight games that we've
announced is that right we're on number
this is the ninth game we've announced
but it's number two yes so go catch up
with all those you can watch our
discussions and our live streams which
you've archived playing those games if
you're watching this live we are going
to be talking about our number one game
of the year which I'm sure nobody knows
what it is but we're gonna be talking
about that in a little while so stick
around